[Música]
hoje eu quero falar sobre uma dor mas é
uma dor diferente é diferente porque ela
não pode ser aliviada nem mesmo pelos
analgésicos
eu me refiro a dor causada pela
injustiça quem sofreu essa dor sabe que
ela é capaz de abalar profundamente o
nosso estado emocional chega a alterar a
nossa freqüência cardíaca prejudica até
mesmo a qualidade do nosso sono não é
basta que assistamos os noticiários para
nós percebemos que as pessoas estão
sofrendo cada vez mais por não saber
lidar com os conflitos humanos
aliás as pessoas somente não as
instituições também estão sofrendo
isso acontece porque elas não sabem como
lidar com tantas e diversificadas
demandas mas se nós prestarmos atenção
aos processos judiciais
nós veremos que no fundo as pessoas
reclamam pelo simples direito de
pertencer que nada mais é do que o
direito de ser visto e respeitado pelo
outro
é claro que num processo judicial elas
expressam isso com outras palavras não é
mas o que importa é que de um modo ou de
outro a injustiça tem por matéria prima
o conflito humano e o que mais me
preocupa é perceber que nós não fomos e
continuamos não nos preparando para
lidar com ele nem mesmo para lidar com
as suas consequências e muito menos para
preveni lo eo incrível pra mim quase
inacreditável é que nós tratamos um
problema que é nosso como se fosse do
outro
aquela pessoa que irá resolvê lo é como
se permanentemente estivéssemos
terceirizando essa tarefa
primeiramente quando crianças talvez por
dever de obediência a delegar vamos aos
nossos pais e depois já adultos nos
repetimos essa conduta
mas aí transferindo essa esse papel é
uma terceira pessoa
o juiz foi assim sensibilizada pela dor
causada pela injustiça mas também
inquieta com a forma como as pessoas e
as instituições lidam com um conflito
humano que eu escolhi a minha missão
o que eu faço bem eu posso explicar
assim as pessoas me contam os seus
problemas
eu ouço a parte contrária aguardo que
comprovem as suas alegações e depois eu
aponto a solução que considera mais
adequada claro faço isso com base num
conjunto de condutas que por convenção
são consideradas corretas como vocês
percebem eu lido com um processo
judiciais e com leis
eu sou juíza de direito mas hoje eu não
gostaria propriamente de falar sobre os
processos ou sobre as intensas que eu
faço todos os dias não eu gostaria de
falar daquele que está diante de mim
o ser humano se nós pensarmos que um
processo judicial guarda importantes
capítulos da história de vida de pelo
menos duas pessoas e se nós percebemos
que elas sofrem os efeitos daquela dor
sobre a qual eu falei no início parece
razoável supor que elas não queiram
prolongar o processo não é mas nem
sempre é assim
não raramente as pessoas olham pra mim e
dizem preferir que eu uma pessoa
totalmente estranha julgue o seu caso é
claro que eu admito e compreendo que nós
não fomos educados para assumir esse
papel nem mesmo pra ver o problema sob o
ângulo do outro onde de regra o cenário
é bem diferente
nós também não nos conscientizamos
o nosso problema ninguém terá uma visão
melhor para identificar os caminhos
possíveis e muito menos melhor
discernimento para escolher um deles e
eu disse
ninguém nem mesmo um juiz mas isso eu
confesso eu não sabia desde o início
quando iniciei minha carreira como juíza
eu achava que seria tão mais eficiente
quanto maior fosse o número de sentenças
que eu fizesse então hoje conforme o
script e fiz aquilo que eu mais sabia
que era julgar julgar e julgar eu
realmente achava que quando assinava uma
sentença estava resolvendo um conflito
de verdade e como eram muitos os
conflitos nessa linha de raciocínio a
consequência lógica não poderia ser
outra não é
eu precisava aumentar a minha capacidade
de produção e quando eu vi estava
completamente envolvida nessa lógica
perversa da velocidade
eu cheguei até mesmo a minha auto
desafiar para tentar conhecer a minha
capacidade máxima de produção eu queria
saber quantas sentenças eu conseguiria
fazer trabalhando maior número de horas
e minutos do meu dia
claro eu fiz isso por um tempo limitado
mas foi o suficiente para perceber que
definitivamente o caminho não era esse
não é nenhuma novidade que o número de
processos que chegam ao poder judiciário
todos os dias é imensamente maior do que
o número dos que saem
aliás nem todos os que saem tem o seu
problema efetivamente resolvido
há casos em que nenhum conjunto de
palavras escritas num papel teria esse
poder
uma sentença por melhor que seja ela
pode muitas vezes agravar ainda mais
aquele relacionamento afastando as
pessoas
isso acontece porque como uma disputa
a sentença confere a uma das partes
o papel o título de vencedor ea outra o
de perdedor
e nós precisamos nos conscientizar de
que quando nós julgamos nos
potencializamos o sentimento da vítima e
fazendo isso nem sempre ajudamos a
resolver o seu problema
tanto é verdade que muitas vezes mesmo
depois de sentenciado o processo a
vítima continua sentindo aquela dor que
está lá dentro latejando e precisamos de
uma vez por todas nos dar conta que
enquanto a vítima sente essa dor ela
pode estar desperdiçando aquilo que nós
temos de mais precioso que é o tempo ele
que sabe ser pau samu quando bem
administrado também sabe ser veneno e eu
digo isso porque na dose errada o tempo
pode comprometer significativamente a
cicatrização das nossas feridas
emocionais e todos nós sabemos que elas
doem muito mais do que qualquer outra
mas apesar de nós termos consciência de
tudo isso continuamos fazendo o mesmo
nós precisamos de uma vez por todas
mudar a direção e justamente por isso eu
gostaria de convidá-los então pra ouvir
a minha história sobre o momento em que
algo aconteceu na minha vida que fez que
o modo com que eu mudasse completamente
a minha direção
lembram quando no início eu disse que
estava tentando aumentar a minha
produtividade no início da carreira
pois é naquela época eu me inscrevi no
curso de pós graduação em gestão e lá eu
aprendi muitas lições que eu aplico
inclusive até hoje
mas eu só não imaginava que a principal
delas viria no último dia estava eu lá
na gráfica pra apanhar a minha
monografia
quando eu levei o maior susto
naquela capa preta com letras douradas
onde deveria estar
inscrito o juiz a gestão ea efetividade
processual não é exatamente isso que
estava escrito
estava escrito o juiz a gestão ea
afetividade processual nossa dessa vez
não eram as leis nem os livros era a
própria vida que estava me
proporcionando um insight sobre o que
realmente estava faltando mais afeto
a mudança dessas útil letrinha da letra
e de efetividade para a letra a de
afetividade fez com que eu deslocasse
completamente a minha atenção para o
principal espaço de afecto onde ocorrem
os maiores aprendizados a nossa família
afinal é lá que desde cedo nós
ministramos as primeiras e mais
importantes lições aos nossos filhos não
é
é lá que como pais nós somos heróis
às vezes sem querer e sem perceber
podemos ser até vilões e ela também na
nossa família que nós somos sabe o que
juízes
bom o fato é que o tempo passou então eu
percebi que eu tinha duas missões e o
mais legal mais interessante é que elas
tenham um ponto em comum entre elas como
juiz eu continuo tendo muitos processos
para receber pra resolver é claro e
muitos mesmo aproximadamente 8 mil e
como mãe de quatro filhos então eu perdi
a conta de quantos problemas eu tenha
resolver ea enfrentar todos os dias mas
o que nós precisávamos perceber é que
nesta coincidência nesta semelhança um
aprendizado gigante porque eu me dei
conta que eu precisava ser o meu melhor
em ambos os papéis e pra ser o melhor em
ambos os papéis
eu precisava assim inverter
completamente a lógica e foi o que eu
fiz
resolvi então diante de uma tarefa tão
difícil
eu não mais como juíza tentar ser uma
mãe melhor mas como mãe tentar ser uma
juíza melhor
antes eu acho que quase que
intuitivamente interpretava em casa o
papel de juíza e eu imagino que vocês
devem estar pensando pobre dessas
crianças não deve ser fácil ser filho de
juiz não é a grande chance de que vocês
façam o mesmo
ou então eu pergunto diante de um
problema qualquer de um desentendimento
em casa ou quando o filho não atende uma
determinação dos pais o que vocês fazem
habitualmente eu imagino que vocês
repreendam o filho ou que deixem até por
algum tempo sem tecnologia não é pois é
vocês estão fazendo o mesmo que eu
julgando é claro que nós temos que
estabelecer os limites para a boa
formação do sistema de valores dos
nossos filhos e disso nós não podemos
abrir mão mas ao fazer isso nós não
podemos deixar de educá los para o
exercício da autonomia o que é muito
mais difícil porque neste campo da
autonomia há um espaço sagrado que é o
espaço da liberdade liberdade para cada
indivíduo ser quem verdadeiramente é
consciente dos seus deveres das suas
ansiedades e dos seus anseios
eu tenho pra mim que só assim os nossos
pequenos cidadãos conseguiram descobrir
como desenvolver essa incrível
habilidade que saber conviver em
sociedade
e digo mais parece me que é justamente
aí que está o problema porque como pais
nós temos sido muito juízes
nós precisamos de uma vez por todas
deixar que nossas crianças subam de
nível no jogo real da própria vida e
eles só conseguirão fazer isso
se nós não continuarmos jogando por eles
tenho pra mim que ele só diz
ó evoluíram só conseguiram alcançar esse
nível tão alto do jogo quando
descobrirem o verdadeiro aprendizado que
há por trás de cada conflito
agora eu entendo porque numa audiência
muitas vezes as pessoas olham pra mim
como olhavam para os pais na infância
parece não terem se dado conta do
potencial que cada um tem dentro de si
de ajudar a buscar a melhor solução para
resolver aquele seu problema talvez de
uma forma que nenhuma sentença jamais
pudesse sequer imaginar
aliás já estudos que comprovam que
quando uma pessoa participa da tomada de
decisão são muito maiores as chances de
que ela cumpra o combinado
e isso acontece porque quando nós
participamos
nós estamos pertencendo quando nos
obrigam não
e esse é o resultado da pesquisa
retratada no livro a estratégia do
oceano azul bom mas o fato é que depois
de me dar conta de tudo isso eu passei a
ter um problema porque para ser coerente
com tudo o que foi dito aqui eu
precisaria mudar também as minhas
atitudes como mãe em relação aos
pequenos inúmeros conflitos que
acontecem no dia a dia mesmo em família
nem é difícil imaginar por quais motivos
disco tem quatro filhos no curso da sua
adolescência não é quem tem filho sabe
mais pra quem não tem eu digo que eles
brigam até mesmo pelo lugar de se sentar
à mesa
mas então o que eu fiz diante de um
conflito qualquer
eu continuo meu impulso de dizer o que
eu considerava certo e realmente eu
admito que é muito mais fácil e rápido
né
mas ao invés disso eu incentivei as
crianças analisarem o problema ea
levantarem diferentes alternativas de
solução e eu digo mais
estas alternativas muitas vezes não
seriam nem mesmo imaginadas por nós
julgadores
quer seja como juiz quer como tais
isso me faz lembrar o repetido episódio
das brigas que ocorriam quando ia buscar
as crianças no colégio
o que era para ser um momento de
encontro de alegria de afetividade se
transformava num momento de stress
porque ele sempre brigavam pelo direito
de sentar no banco dianteiro
como nenhuma das alternativas de solução
que eu propus tinham dado certo até
porque pra mim parecia suficiente um
simples revezamento eu os desafio é
tentar encontrar uma alternativa de
solução que eles fizeram isso analisaram
todas as variáveis por exemplo em qual
dia da semana determinado filho não
regressaria para casa por conta das
atividades extra curriculares
enfim eles criaram um critério que
consideraram justo às vezes eu quando
vou buscá-los ao colégio no colégio nem
mesmo sei de quem é o dia de se sentar
naquele banco dianteiro mas isso também
já não importa porque eles sabem e
respeitam
então se como mãe e como juíza eu
pudesse dar um conselho a vocês pais
eu diria o seguinte amem seus filhos
abracem fortemente seus filhos e nesse
ambiente da mais pura confiança
incentive os a se colocar no lugar do
outro
ao ouvir o outro analisar o problema sob
diferentes perspectivas e depois a
discutir sobre as possibilidades de
solução e eu garanto a vocês que mesmo
que eles nunca tenham lido sequer um
artigo de lei
aliás mesmo que eles nem saibam ler
eles já terão condições de desenvolver
seu próprio senso de justiça
este pra mim é um dos maiores e mais
importantes legados que podemos deixar
as próximas gerações e eu concluir isso
quando descobri que melhor que a
expectativa de uma decisão
nada por um terceiro é a sensação de ter
ajudado a lapidar a própria solução como
se estivéssemos encontrando remédio que
vai curar ou aliviar a nossa dor
se esta fosse uma lei seria impossível
revogá-la
a pergunta que fica é precisa ser lei
não nem nós precisamos ser juízes
obrigado
[Aplausos]